[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we're very
careful very very very careful careful
that's our new show it's the careful
boys show
today for the very first time on camera
boys we have
bobby deen
hey who is a very careful girl
wait so careful i would like to think so
that's the question that's how you start
the show would you say you're careful
yeah
pretty soon camera i didn't hear the
whole story off camera you guys said you
met on a a a sketch or a another show
tim tim show yeah we met through tim
uh but was it a skit yeah i don't think
it ever came out right i think i was his
mom yes you were yeah
i played his mom yeah give us give us
the synopsis of the skit real quick uh
i'm pretty sure somehow i was like the
hood rat girlfriend always don't know
why tim likes that role for me sure
yeah he likes that role you're like the
total opposite from that too but i think
it's just like it it works
in the world that's true
they have their own idea
oh yeah the whole world thinks you're
the hood rat girlfriend i don't know
people just like to assume stuff but you
know that's just the internet what would
you assume that most people assume of
you well what i know just because of
like what they tell me and stuff is
always like for some reason everybody
thinks i have money
no hey y'all let's give to the economy
class over here y'all send it my way oh
actually contributing make it to
yeah you're rich but they think you're
poor or you're poor but they think
you're rich i think that one when you're
poor but they think you're rich
for sure because i'm cool with being
rich and people thinking i'm poor like i
don't give a [ __ ] i got my money
well um you also had mentioned uh
because i was asking you just like what
you did and you mentioned that uh for
your daytime you work in the cannabis
industry yes and
um and then you said that uh you also
work in the industry as like a model and
stuff like that right mm-hmm those two
worlds intersect and collide
yeah
absolutely i mean i've done that i've
done some modeling for some cannabis
companies but i mean usually on set
somebody's smoking somebody's smoking
something you know so yeah i feel like
all the photo shoots are at a grow up
and you just hold in the joint or like
you have some vape or like some kind of
product
or like a lotion cbd lotion and it's
just in a grow up is it sometimes is it
true that thc is the most important
thing as long as you have the most chc
that is good [ __ ] no that is a lie
because blend right like a blend of the
thc and the cpu we had a guy who sat
here saying the opposite
did the guy work in the industry yeah he
said he did no he said he said the
opposite of what you said
he was teaching you
testing you no no i'm like no no yeah no
no what do you know about about cannabis
yeah thc cbd what are we supposed to
look for well everybody has different i
guess like a different reason to be
using it some people do it recreational
some people do it medicinally whatever
works for you cool trying to be an
absolute father what should i
no not that hey sometimes
sometimes thc can help some people get
it together you know so hey no judgment
here but
i mean i'm a fan of cbd i think you need
it to kind of offset your thc yeah um
you just if you're trying to get high i
guess you don't want to have too much
cbd because then that's going to keep
you more chill oh cbd chills you out and
the thc gets you high absolutely there's
a whole lot of other stuff in there if
you see the
there's like and then the different
things do different [ __ ] and i don't
know
but everyone just focuses on a thc yes
because that's the psychedelic aspect of
it and i can tell you because of the
trap industry or that side of it um
people mouse trucks
no no the other kind trapezoid industry
um that whole theory of like the the
number needs to be high was created by
those people to push certain products
that were not tested legally so wait a
minute you're giving us some juice on
something that probably affects my lungs
potentially the same thing and he's in
the industry everyone that's in the
industry says the same exact thing that
thc is all what noobs just focus on yes
there's so much more to it but then they
just all go
but it's like all of it put together and
then the ratio is what matters
and that's what gives the different
effects they're like i'm trying to get
high as [ __ ] give me the highest team
right and that doesn't always mean that
and what might work for you to get you
really still might not work for me so
that's also kind of silly in that aspect
to be like the biggest number like
that's not gonna work for everybody
i'm actually pretty happy that it's
getting closer and closer to like fully
legal now because i remember in high
school
it's just the luck of the draw whatever
your dealer has no [ __ ] yeah pretty much
like a [ __ ] bag of stems yeah it
could be like the worst [ __ ] in the
world and who knows but she was waiting
for them to be like yo we got that
norcal weed though
the quality is getting better you're not
getting shit's gonna [ __ ] you up have
you guys gone to like dispensary oh yeah
there's some crazy ones in vegas i'll
see and that's i've never gone to the
vegas ones but i recently heard that the
videos ones are a little bit more
advanced in the sense that like the
information that they provide on the
jars and on the products there's our
[ __ ] ipads in front of them
we have ipads too but over here it's
very like apple like they just try to
get you in and out and it's just walking
around with the ipad but i feel like
with more information
that's actually like slowing down the
process because now you can ask
questions or be like well what does this
mean what does this mean yeah i'm here
i'm a pastor now so i'm smoking it's
also still like new right now for a lot
of people right so i think once like
either enough time or a generation that
spends enough time in a legalized
perspective or some sort of hive
mentality it's like alcohol most people
that go to the bar now
it's not like you're sitting there
asking every question unless you're
[ __ ] noob right and wasting the
bartender's time and everybody else i'm
not wasting his time okay
i need to know what's going on but you
know what i mean it takes a taste
because it's always like hey it tastes
like cotton candy i'm like it tastes
like weed
you don't ever you don't even like
edibles specifically i'm talking about
cbd even they're like hey this one you
know this is a gumdrop and i'm like it's
weed
it doesn't taste like it's but it's like
alcohol we know alcohol well right at
the end of the day it's gonna taste like
alcohol oh bro spicy tamarind vodka from
smirnoff tastes like [ __ ] spicy
tamarind bro yeah bruh smearing off me
one time
it's the bomb get out of here if you
don't like the smoking or the tasting
there's edibles
that's true i don't like to eat the weed
why not you like edibles it takes too
long
it takes like hours i want to get high
immediately i have a totally dip my like
i can smoke like i could hit bonds but
if i hit
eat edibles like i need to like make
sure i'm in a safe space just in case
like i react to it way differently when
it's a different height
it makes me sleepy more psychedelic i
found out what happens is uh when your
body
when it goes through your liver it
creates an additional metabolite so now
you're even more high so you're like
double high i mean it's more psychedelic
kind of right yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] with
me because it feels like a delic with a
edible
i feel less psychedelic on an edible i
feel way more body high
i feel like i'm out of my body dude i'm
like looking down on my body i'm [ __ ]
yeah
are you sure this is weed
hey man smoking by itself is already
psychedelic for me i feel like the
edibles got better though especially
with like the milligram doses
like you know exactly how much that's
always been the hardest part before
because people would just show and be
like yo i got some brownies and you have
no tell you anything how strong you take
a crumb corner is hella strong if this
corner is like nothing right it's not
standardized now standardized thank god
but even then it's so it's
i think there's mad gray area a lot of
brands are different too like 50
milligrams of one brand 50 milligrams
over here is completely different but
beyond just weed though like now there's
like [ __ ] what is that like the the
[ __ ] wax [ __ ] that they yeah oh and
then which is healthier what is it what
do you do with the water sort of
healthier really it's like you're
smoking cracked think about well yes for
the people that are not like familiar
with cannabis it can be a little
intimidating because of that it does
look a little cracky yeah
whatever what do you do with the wax
butter it's like concentrated
yes
that's how you get hot vicks vaporub dog
just put it right here when you got
stuffy nose bro you basically i mean
with wax you can use it out of like a
bong but then you have to melt it with
something which some people pour there
you go a torch other people add it just
directly to their weed and roll up
i mean there's just many ways to do it
but it's concentrated concentrated
that's the key word concentrated so
think of it like i would say think of it
like a shop versus a mixed drink
if you want a instant high you take a
shot and i think it's high already also
also when you don't want like the sugar
of a cocktail that like makes you feel
funky or like it's too much or whatever
sometimes you want the purity or the
cleanliness of a shot and that's what
the wax does that's what wax kind of
without the bird there's no there's no
like a burn of the butane from your
lighter to like the actual charring of
burnt
plants you know what i'm saying like
actually
hey but everybody doesn't think that you
know and i was gonna say though if
you're not a smoker i would not
recommend starting off with wax that's
you know that's like for the big boys
like you gotta work your way up to that
you can't just try that out what's your
preferred way of consuming cannabis um
ideally i would like to roll up like
with actual bud but it is it is smelly i
got a lot of hair i'm not trying to give
it away that i smoke you know i like to
smell like a lady
doesn't it go away it goes away off like
a day right
it's chicken yeah thick chick hair is
different yeah that's every [ __ ]
smell you know your shirt she's talking
about big chicken without the thickest
hair on the universe yeah i mean maybe
not as sick as yours but it's crazy
thick no she's got thick hair though you
can smell it and i can smell everywhere
she's been she got that foxy cleopatra
hair right now though you know post
office and costco in there yep yeah but
seriously though little korean barbecue
you smell that [ __ ] because i haven't
smelled that goldfish i got pretty sharp
though today's video is brought to you
by feels cbd is not about what you feel
it's about what you do not feel such as
like stress
anxiety oh ouch pain i got punched in
the shoulder damn girl relax i know
sometimes it makes sex better too
sex with yourself or sex with other
people it helps you relax sometimes you
need to get out of your mind because you
have such a hectic day and you just need
a whole type of routine to unwind cbd
helps me with that especially the feels
process baby yeah the other we've been
busy so me and jill hadn't have sex in
like three months they're about to have
sex and i'm like oh [ __ ] i think i'm a
virgin again i feel so nervous and so i
don't want to prematurely ejaculate into
my pants so i did the joe method play
the skin flute first
take
some feels feel relaxed now i feel like
rico suave and then when we had sex we
felt way more sensualized into and all
the nervousness was gone and that's a
pretty easy process you know you just
take a few drops of the fields and it
makes you feel great and what's awesome
is they have a hotline if you do not
know what to do you feel a little bit
intimidated well they'll help you walk
through this whole entire process and
it's awesome because when you order this
it just comes to your door you don't
have to walk into a store or anything
like that it's a pretty easy experience
that's probably my favorite thing is i
always like counting on things being
there so if you sign up for their
membership it comes to your door every
single month and you get a discount
which is freaking awesome so you can
always rely on having it when you need
it so make sure you go check them out if
you want to feel good feel relaxed get
rid of some anxiety
f-e-a-l-s dot com fields dot com slash
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's a big
old discount and i know how much our
asian listings love discount
videos.com f-e-a-l-s dot com slash off
the record to get fifty percent off plus
free shipping thank you very much she
got the scary movie here when you roll
it up in the bed she and lighter here
see there you go
you know what i'm talking about i like
the smell of weed on people i do too but
some people get like super offended by
it
well it's because sometimes it's
it's on people that also smell like sour
sweat and they haven't
showered in a long time
i feel you on that part sometimes it
kind of covers the bo so people can't
smell themselves yeah i don't like that
combo but i do like i'd rather smell
their weed than their bo
dude i have a barber that had like the
worst breath and like he would smoke
like a oh he had to caught him now bro
and i could and he would be like talking
to me in my ear while he's cutting my
hair and i was like oh my god bro it
smells like you ate a [ __ ] sandwich
with a hint of like cannabis you know
great barber though great barbecue
r.i.p r.i.p wrestling oh
[ __ ] dang and he's getting roasted he
passed away
so you say you said you go out um and
kind of been are like a spokesperson or
ambassador for like the cannabis company
you work for right so what does that
like look like what does that entail was
it day to day for you i mean it can be
different things sometimes i can go
literally to a dispensary and just talk
to the customers there kind of like a
little costco vibe with my own little
kiosk stand and whatnot and then other
times we do
samples
back in the days before it became legal
yes we were able to give samples and it
was epic it was great but
now we can't do that because some people
do get insanely high from one little
puff and we don't want them to be high
in driving you know oh
yeah safe
but we also do like really big events
like we had done a really big concert a
few months ago um for some really big
artists and it's great you know people
are there to party halfway named artist
named artist um big drop name drop i
could name drop yg oh [ __ ] so pretty
pretty big um and yeah just like events
like that you get to just talk to people
and just provide the focus
like why the [ __ ] is what dude you don't
know what i do uh dude i'm not good at
this [ __ ] you heard the music
you haven't heard
hey hey let's give him some credit he's
an actor now okay what's he mean um he
was in that one movie um was that little
boy something um
oh walk to remember oh no no
he wasn't in that movie
notebook no it's a notebook
thank you he was in that movie something
something um
the little little white kid that was
like the drug dealer he was in bright
he wasn't bright
i don't know he was in gary
my bad swipe boy why boy red rick i
haven't heard that you haven't seen that
is any good yes what's it about
basically this white kid that was like
allegedly selling drugs but he wasn't it
was the whole like fbi like putting
stuff on him because they were like a
freeway uh ricky ross type of situation
not as crazy i mean it was pretty crazy
though because they pinned him for so
many years but they were using him to be
an informant oh and then after that they
still sent him to prison so it was like
whoa
that's crazy
sorry wow
winner alert this is like a movie i like
to watch though yeah it was really good
you should bart's never going to watch
it but it's fine i am going to watch it
he's never going to watch it dude
[ __ ] like that though like how do you
feel about maybe this is like way too
serious but like you know how you know
how like um there's people that are
incarcerated around or in jail for like
having like [ __ ] a nug of weed and
they're like it's [ __ ] serving like
lifetime and [ __ ] right like as a world
that we live in continues like you said
to [ __ ] legalize it social
stereotypes of it continue to change kim
kardashian's gonna get them all out
that's what she wants to do
hey she she's really out here though
that's the whole reason why she goes to
law school dude one of the biggest
things about cannabis or like marijuana
why it became illegal was to control the
minority population because
they were the ones smoking it go ahead
preach yeah
wait really kim kardashian's legal
journey is she's been doing that yeah
yeah yeah specifically she's trying to
be a lawyer people but people that have
just been wrongfully yeah gotcha yeah
yeah okay huge part of that thing yeah
okay where's this is community and stuff
that's what she's been working on dude
anyone can do it it's kim kardashian i
know right
and when she comes in this world sure
yeah yeah i'll give it to her
she got the eyes on her you know what i
mean she doesn't know kanye could smell
that she was at law school on her hair
well she ain't got the gay around her no
more hey yo no more
i don't know where do you think he is
now in paris
i don't know he's got a crazy haircut
that's all over the internet didn't he
start a cult or something yeah that's
why he was like i thought he was like in
wyoming or something like some ranch out
there yeah dude what was it there was a
picture of him chilling with this guy
michael cohen right and he was wearing
like a white like a white mask do you
guys see that no pull up that picture
dude it's crazy what kanye whiteface
yeah yeah dude it's hilarious
i don't know jabbawockeez
he's pretty much a java wonky now bro
you know michael was eating at a
restaurant and kanye was there and he
didn't realize it until he left oh yeah
yeah he told us that story yeah i saw
kanye at uh soho house in downtown oh
[ __ ] there are people surrounding
walking by himself no no he was uh the
whole downstairs was like uh inside uh
it was like just his big ass meeting it
was him at a giant circle table and is
that the mask him at a table and like 20
people around like they were in a big
business meeting wow was that really him
though i literally walked by and i was
like who knows did he have like big ass
security around him no no
that's definitely connie's eyes in there
that's kanye
wait are you serious it's a signature
bomber jacket there was a picture of him
sitting with michael cohen and they're
chilling in a cafe wait you're saying
that's kanye it's that's a different
picture than what i saw
but there was a picture of a mess right
i think so yeah why'd he do that for i
don't know that looked like the jason
manning be controversial talking about
just like that ugly haircut yeah dude
and he's like cause i'm a [ __ ]
billionaire yeah it looks like his kid
cut his hair what happened to his hair
it's just ugly it's it's red
it's bad it's bad i can give you the
same haircut yeah you want to hook me up
dude yeah bro he's like but you know if
his kid did that to him you'd be like
all right cool well it was kind of fire
like yeah i feel like the divorce wasn't
his
choices and everything it wasn't his
choice right they said they said that um
he said some very very [ __ ] up stuff
about his marriage and that his publicly
yes oh it was when he was running for
president and his barber got passed well
no not that part not
[Music]
you wanted your child available like
it's just wait
what i don't even remember when that
happened what's the context like why did
he say that like in public he's probably
obviously he ransom says a lot of things
that he shouldn't publicly yeah just
think about that kid in school they're
gonna be like you should have been a boy
yeah even your dad thinks so yeah
also what are the kids now like yes one
of the kids that's like currently with
the yeah
that's wild dude yeah
so they allegedly say that yeah he
deserves one
last thing for kim did you listen to his
last album donda some of it did you like
it yeah it's cool i think he makes great
music so to be honest i think it had
more substance than uh than drake's i
liked it a lot dude
it's great different yeah doesn't talk
about solid stuff uh you know he still
had like more you have some bangers
though feels good drake's just like
always all like love [ __ ] yeah yeah club
and love something that you dance and
turn up to kanye you're not gonna hear
donda in the club like oh i know this
kanye's like artistry well i mean
they're both artists but then one
focuses on love and relationships and
common people stuff and then kanye's
like out of this world [ __ ] yeah well
kanye was actually talking about jesus
and his mom mainly so
technically also relatable to the
conversation his mom's name by the way
what a cool name dude
[Music]
[Music]
you